welcome to this video film or more from
made me do something don't do something
wired feel more from Sweden let's play
the red team yeah this is a very solid
set up that black can employ six d5 g6
quite quite okay for white definitely um
but nothing special okay I'd like to get
in before if you place a foursome a3
looks like a good the good choice it's
not able to play me5 I have a good
control over 85 one disadvantage of
putting the night on the rim and then
yeah what is White's plan here probably
just go here and maybe I should have
played h3 let's do this now make sure I
get the bishops for the mode that's
unexpected dropping it back can play if
or if I like
not bad but I can also play em maybe you
can play be five if I go bishops III but
still I want to play Bishop c3 queen bee
to maybe be four before would be nice
too oh that's that's a weird move b6
what is the idea it just weakens lots of
stuff and I don't see what is what what
the positive side is ok let's just do
the normal things queen bee to
impressing the pressure on the diagonal
in some cases i might play g4 and g5 win
win apiece aha so after be four years
night a form i see Knight d4 you should
be 70 probably i see interesting maybe
here to prepare before 96 Bishop b5 is a
slight improvement for me i cannot play
g45 winning a pieces last night h5 um
before here let's let's get it in for
some reason I'm done on time and this is
a no in an opening that I already know I
guess I'm helpless Bishop b5 um how do
you what do you do against g4 winning in
peace now trapping your own bishop p.m.
now I strapped to some Bishop him okay
there's some no not really some point
some move at a point I guess I should
just take it let's see how how to
convert this any anything special and
probably should open the diagonal even
more if he takes on b5 I think I have 95
this should be to Bishop takes d5 would
be terrific
my king is fairly safe i mean i'm
lacking the two pawns but he is no he's
good no attacking pieces at the moment
but on the other king okay um if i take
take their night c4 hmm it's still a
convenient pen maybe just put this here
this is not a bad bad spot rook a7 and
d5 hang so i took me some time to
recognize that yeah i think this should
be should be just a winning up we can
take care now and now i can take you
seven play d6 and curtains I think check
well that's it d6 attacking the Queen
the rook e8 everything everything hangs
d6 also was good alright it's still
quite nice
black resigns it wrapped his own mission
but at this moment black already is
under some pressure watch what he did is
play some weakening was on the queenside
this is already and it's nothing
brilliant or anything but white is
definitely more comfortable here because
I have some clear plans Queen b2 b4 b5
and it's not clear what black is doing
the computer gives a beehive as the best
line after that I can go here this
that's important I don't want to take
give him give him the open sea file this
is not bad for a white saying that but
still okay for black probably as well
nothing too brilliant c5 however is good
it it tends to play b5 before you cannot
take this will lead to a material again
and it's not clear what you should do I
also have this g4 move available it was
a bit strange that after Bishop to g4
when dope so sorry when I went h3 you
should definitely take this simply based
on the fact that um the bishop pair is
not that great at the moment for me
because he can almost all the time
exchange on the long diagonal even 97
immediately he as possible with a
position that let's say after the
capture deform is probably a slightly
better for white but nothing nothing
special really and here he has of case
where this Bishop is just the liability
it's not really helping him in any way
okay b6 i have f also all the time with
a good position but i thought that this
is this is quite quite nice and keeps
good controller before is coming here
yeah here it gets it gets ugly where
where should he go with this piece
back maybe but it falls into place I
have much better working pieces here why
it is already very very much better I
mean this is really just giving up a
piece he could play 97 as a as an
improvement I bet just very slightly if
we look at this 94 that's it's really
terrible d5 Hanks f5 is attacked adds
just better for white the t I'd was just
a piece and an easy win okay thanks for
watching